it needs to cancel the cut to universal
credit um the government
um pretends that it's interested in
leveling up
you cannot level up if you're going to
take a thousand pounds a year
from the six million families who are
struggling to make ends meet and
you know many things in the pandemic
which were awful but one of the things
in the pandemic that was good was that
we looked after each other and here
coming out of the pandemic you've got
the government turning
on those most in need and this will
drive people into poverty and drive them
into a place that's very very difficult
for them on energy what's the
alternative to the energy price cap
rising again if in spring gas prices
continue to rise
plan plan plan plan but
we've got a government that governs in
chaos instead of planning so on energy
they've been warned over many years
about the gas storage that we needed and
they let it go they were warned that
nuclear was stalling not going quickly
enough and warned about diversification
so um this is a government that um you
know tries to govern in slogans
but is finding that the failure to plan
is hitting working people up and down
the country what we've got here is
universal credit being cut by a thousand
pounds a year thousand pounds a year for
families that desperately need it the
same time prices are going up getting
hit from both ends by a government
that's pretending that there isn't a
problem there
just back to universal credit how would
you how would labour pay for the six
billion and cost of university credit
what we would do is we would
not cut a thousand pounds a year from
the families who most needed we would
put up um the minimum wage to 10 pounds
an hour to give people the chance to
earn that extra money and we would work
with business not treat business as the
enemy three years ago boris johnson the
prime minister uh told business uh where
to go
not in those words
now he's acting it out treating business
as the enemy so we would take a
completely different approach on this we
spent some time with three families in a
special report today on sky news bills
are piling up around them citizens of
ice says calls are up by a third for
them millions of families are now trying
to avoid hunger and hardship what's your
response to our report that we've put
out today i think it's
shockingly accurate about the human
impact that this will have on millions
of families these are people that helped
us through the pandemic
they're the people who most need this
money and how on earth can the
government claim claim to be interested
in leveling up you cannot level up if
you turn on the six million families who
most need
that support and at the same time as
this money is coming out through the cut
that the government is imposing prices
are going up it's a it's being hit from
both ends by families who are getting
increasingly desperate so on that is 500
million pounds the winter hardship fund
from the government is that enough no
it's a drop in the ocean it's nowhere
near enough um and the government is
ignoring this problem we had um a speech
from the prime minister this week um in
my opinion it was a load of old baloney
absolutely nothing in it and he didn't
even have the respect the respect to
address the six million people who are
going to lose this money um this week or
begin to lose this money over a prom
period and the impact it's going to
happen he didn't even have the respect
to businesses to say what's the plan
to get us through the next stage given
the chaos that this government is
causing okay you're up in the north of
england michael gove is the man for
levelling up here is he the right man
for the job do you think well it's not a
question whether he's the right man it's
what how on earth can the government
claim to be leveling up when it's
hitting six million families who most
need it with a thousand pound cup if you
can't level up those that are most in
need you're not interested in leveling
up
in an alternative space on schools we
know there's a bigger gap in our school
children now because of the pandemic
there was already a big attainment gap
the government took expert advice on
what needed to be done and then he said
no you cannot be serious about leveling
up if you're
if you're going to cut
you know much needed support from
families that are most in need and at
the same time not level up our children
that's not serious about leveling up and
finally he told us that he would beat
you in a quiz about the north of england
would he
no i don't think uh it beat me in the
north of england or any other part of
england um but you know
i hate to break this to you but this is
a prime minister that doesn't always
tell the truth